la droite conserve sa majorité au Sénat
c'est également le cas dans le
département la liste une équipe pour
toutes les Yvelines menées par Gérard
Larcher arrivent en tête des
sénatoriales avec plus de 57% des voix
elle perce pendant un siège par rapport
à la précédente mandature ce
renouvellement sénatorial conforte la
majorité sénatoriale de la droite et du
centre est témoigne de son ancrage
territorial dans un contexte politique
marqué par l'absence de majorité au sein
de l'Assemblée nationale plus que jamais
le Sénat incarne ce pôle de stabilité ce
point d'équilibre de la République face
à la crise profonde que traverse notre
pays en deuxième position ensemble agir
pour les Yvelines la liste
des présidentielles conduite par Martin
lévrier conserve son siège avec près de
15% des voix
accompli et
qui a su gagner presque 90 voix en 6 ans
donc ce qui est un une preuve d'une
véritable implantation même auprès des
élus du département et ça c'était très
très important de montrer que le terrain
nous étions sur le terrain et que nous
avions valorisé le terrain mais la
grande surprise de ces sénatoriales
vient de la gauche une nouvelle voie
pour les Yvelines totalise un peu plus
de 13% des suffrages la tête de liste
Ghislaine Séné obtient donc un siège la
gauche yvelinoise fait son retour au
Palais du Luxembourg après 6 ans
d'absence
et bien quand
les parties de goût de bouche se font
l'Union dans les Yvelines et ben en fait
grâce à cela on a pu retrouver le poste
que nous avions perdu en 2017 je crois
que la voix de de l'écologie
et de la solidarité doit se faire plus
entendre au Sénat dans les Yvelines 8
listes étaient candidates notamment le
rassemblement national et la France
insoumise qui arriver ait en quatrième
et cinquième position elle ne décroche
pas de siège quant au sénateur élu ils
entreront en fonction le 2 octobre
prochain première séance dédiée à
l'élection du président de la Chambre
haute